let's uh talk a little bit about radical
republican congresswoman marjorie taylor
greene really the worst of the worst of
american politics if you imagine for a
second oh let's say we were sending some
elected officials to you know pick a
country wherever ireland to represent
the best of the united states house and
senate marjorie taylor green is
basically the most humiliating person
you could send along with a couple
others madison cawthorne louis gomer
lauren beauberg matt matt gates
these types of people okay so she's uh
facing some problems the first problem
is that a judge has ruled
that the effort to remove marjorie
taylor green from her re-election ballot
in november upcoming now in a few months
can go forward now the judge hasn't said
she's off the ballot the judge has said
the effort can in principle go forward
this is absolutely fascinating and this
is going to be a legal fight so let me
explain what's going on or or we're
going to look at the new york times
report from this morning a federal judge
cleared the way
for a group of georgia voters to move
forward with legal efforts seeking to
disqualify green
from running for re-election why well
citing her role in the trump riots the
disqualification effort is based on a
constitutional provision adopted after
the civil war that barred members of the
confederacy from holding office
it mirrors several other cases involving
republican members of congress whose
roles leading up to enduring the trump
riots have drawn criticism the judge was
appointed to the district court for the
northern district of georgia by
president barack obama and denied
marjorie taylor green's request for a
preliminary injunction and temporary
restraining order
um
in the 73-page ruling judge tottenberg
wrote that green had failed to meet the
burden of persuasion in her request for
injunctive relief this case involves a
whirlpool of colliding constitutional
interest of public import the novelty of
the factual and historical posture
especially assessed in the context of a
preliminary injunction motion has made
resolution of the complex legal issues
particularly demanding
the argument that green made is there's
no way to resolve this fully before the
primary on may 24th and absentee ballots
are going to start being mailed in on
april 25th so there's there's no way to
fully adjudicate this in time
and um
the argument from the judge here is
green is arguing sort of like procedure
like the the primaries really soon and
there's no way to decide this now the
judge determined green hasn't shown that
it's likely she would succeed on the
merits
so
she went but marjorie taylor green went
on tucker carlson's show last night
and she's flipping out listen to what
she had to say i have to protect myself
i have to go to court on friday and
actually be questioned about something
i've never been charged with and
something i was completely against and
so this is how far it's going these
leftists these progressives who would
rather want they'd rather have the judge
or bureaucrats making decisions instead
of voters they want to hand that over to
them and not let the people in my
district to even have the right to vote
for me but no the republican party now
that's a very dishonest argument because
this is sort of like saying
hey you know um
uh there's rules about who can be in the
house and senate and for example if a
member of the house were convicted of a
crime and then uh forced to resign
anybody could get up there and say you
know what
the right of the people to just decide
given that this individual was convicted
of a crime do we still want them
representing us or not that's being
denied to them right but these are the
rules these are the rules and the law is
you can move to have someone taken off
of a ballot
if you can prove that they did certain
things
that so it it's it's very naive or
cynical or just dishonest to say oh the
people aren't being allowed to just
voice their opinion well there are times
where we say you can't be on the ballot
to fight harder tucker you know there's
something that we that i have learned
and i think this is really important you
know if you can challenge any
representatives candidacy or elective
elected office holder then i bet you we
could round up some republican voters
who didn't like kamala harris by the way
still can't pronounce kamala's name
funding uh rioters criminal rioters out
of jail or ilhan omar or corey bush or
maxine waters now what do those four
women have in common hold on a second
kamala harris ilhan omar corey bush
maxine waters there's something similar
about them right i'm trying to what why
is she mentioning those four exciting
riots you know i think there's there's
another way to play this game now of
course
uh
this is also absurd what she says
because this is exactly what they did to
joe biden's win she's like you can't
just have people
challenge whatever anybody anybody's
position but joe biden won and that's
exactly what all of you guys did you
were like no he didn't win he doesn't
get to be there
there was no evidence for it there was
no legal basis there was no factual
basis there was no empirical basis
so um this is actually a very
interesting legal case
if this were to work against marjorie
taylor green to keep her off the ballot
you in theory could use it against other
pro-insurrection pro-riot politicians
and i'm sure that if this goes against
marjorie taylor-green she will try to
appeal and maybe it would get all the
way up to the supreme court because
they're actually i don't want to pretend
that the legal issue is cut and dry i
read a bunch of opinions this morning
and this comes down to the 14th
amendment so there is a constitutional
issue as to whether you really could
keep her off the ballot in this way
there's a mechanism to request it
and if it were
successful there would be a question as
to whether it's constitutional but
uh that doesn't matter it's a process
that is going through and her disdain
for having to participate in a legal
process aside from what your opinion is
of what the outcome should be is the
exact type of entitlement
that we've seen from these people for so
very long but this isn't the only
problem that marjorie taylor green is
having let's go to the next one if
you're looking for a therapist or
seeking treatment for mental health or
substance abuse check out compassionate
care compassionate care is a medical
practice offering
mental health treatment that's
affordable
and remote
in the comfort of your home
compassionate care offers remote talk
therapy to patients nationwide you can
establish a meaningful long-term
relationship without having to drive to
an office for every appointment
psychiatry services are available
remotely to patients in pennsylvania and
new york compassionate care offers
medication assisted treatment for opioid
or alcohol addiction with the
medications buprenorphine and naltrexone
available in pennsylvania new york and
delaware compassionate care does not
require insurance they're a small
independent practice they support the
david pakman show and you can support
them and they're ready to talk to you
get a free consultation by calling 855
208
2408 or go to
caredrs.com the link is down below